hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play suicide mouse
now this cheerfully titled game was
suggested to me by none other than
yamimash himself so I didn't steal it I
didn't steal it from him
but I wanted to but he told me about
before it looks like I steal all of his
other games okay here we go
this is based off some sort of
creepypasta I kind of glossed over it a
little bit it was really weird I it's
hard to describe I mean in a lot of ways
I don't want to spoil it for you if you
guys want to go read the creepypasta
before you watch the video there is
probably a link in the description or
you can just look up suicide Mouse but
as far as the game goes I haven't seen
anything about it
so you're a gangly looking let's call a
murky mouse cuz we don't want any
copyright infringement so murky over
here is doing something hello what
happened I just fell through the floor
jump in the phone died yeah cuz I threw
myself into the fire isn't that ah come
on what the hell well isn't that stupid
so I thought I thought this Oh what the
hell give me higher I'm next
okie dokie okie dokie artichokie
so I'm guessing the icon in the top left
means that I can interact with something
in the environment can I hang myself
from
well lift that's exactly what I did good
for me what I died
well I hung myself from the hook and
that my body exploded into pieces I'm in
the hanging yourself part yeah but
exploding afterwards so excessive don't
you think is weird
hi are you dead - get out hi don't tell
me what to do
I'm gonna go in all these houses hi
leave now the screw you don't you know
who I am
I'm murky Mouse save yourself
I don't think I can I am dead you're
next
okay jump down in the hole for some
stupid reason I jump down in hole hi
okay got it jump across this chasm whoo
intense graphics going on here whoosh oh
man
it's so awesome hello wait did they get
it I can't move okay I'm out
I can't go back what happened what
happened what happened oh no don't tell
me somehow with my magical braking
powers I think I broke the murky mass
what are you doing here hi who was that
homie homie Sampson ho just refer to
everyone every every copyrightable
character by some other name I broke the
game I got it I'll be back okay we're
back now sorry about that
I horrible habit where any game that I'm
playing no matter what I do I can break
it if I didn't break it and I'm supposed
to do something else it wasn't very
obvious what else what to do so I don't
know whatever whatever let's just jump
down the holy and it wasn't that far see
what's going on in the rest of this
horrifying environment of a
world I guess you could call this whoosh
whoosh whoosh okay what is all that
about what is that about
hello what what is you about if I jump
over here will i okay now I can move
okay I did I did I broke the game
somehow I homie homie Sampson okay what
what do i do do i jump down there I
probably I'm down here oh well this
isn't good hi what the hell was that
ah it's right on my face hello
go away please ah hey it's just like
bodies of me disintegrating ah no I
mercury don't like none of you what the
hell I died oh it knows where to go in
the hole I can't wait in this game I'm
so bad
okay I think I gotta go to the end get
the thing and then come back across the
pit don't jump in any random holes that
you see in real life don't jump down any
strange holes the rabbit hole does not
exist you won't go to Wonderland your
father just died or a horriffic Lieb
like that okay let's just get our do
daddy and get it so murky can have happy
fun times
oh no the Cheshire Cat
hello can i house you no no my thingy oh
no oh no maybe I'm supposed to like
hurry up and maybe no I was gonna fall
out okay so what do I do about this huh
what do i do what do I do
or did I just did I fail maybe there is
like a time limit now I need to get the
thing I don't know haha what the hell
what was that glowy thing anyway it went
away before I could get it maybe maybe I
need to get it I don't know let's go buy
jump again I am derd iron iron what is
that from that that you died look
familiar
I swear does okay so let's hurry hurry
hurry try to get to somewhere another
where finally did a Wahoo were here I
don't even know why we're joining murky
on this magical adventure in the
horrific land hello man he's forced to
spend eternity in this hell where it'll
die over and over again so let's just go
as quickly as we can quick quick quick
quick quick like bunny and quick like
bunny quick like mousey quick quick
quick quick quick quick quick come on
come on come on go go go and get yeah I
got
I think that Durrell oh I don't think
that actually did anything haha don't
think that help me at all
wait what the hell is that
maybe it give me some sort of like super
protection now I can go in the hole and
I'll be just fine and dandy ha oh no I
missed what the that was not on that was
not on there I'm just doing my awkward
shuffle over I'm shuffling off to
Buffalo
let me mute I got a magical device of
borderless or maybe I'm supposed to
press space on the thingy oh good
what was that I saw something there what
did that say never gonna go back and
pause the video right there
what did that say no I want to go home
this is so weird this is so freaky
murky murky go home to Bernie Bernie
that's his mouthy wife okay I got it I'm
gonna try to go over there as quick as
quick as I can and then then I'm gonna
press the use button on it go go go go
go what the hell is that
what kind of awkward shuffle are you
doing get it get it get it get it gonna
get together oh come on oh right now I
show the icon chains floating on air
why what the hell is this that's not
right how do I break these games so bad
oh I don't know go away douche I'm dead
I'm dead
Thank You let's get it done
tired of wandering this purgatory I want
to get it done I want to get it over and
done fish I'm bad at breaking games I
just do it all the freakin time
go go then go go go go and go and go and
hit all right I hit it I hit it so hard
I hit it so good I hit it as hard as I
could
hey that round I'm gonna guess turn I
don't know what that said you can't stop
you stop messing with me stop wasting
with my brain
everyone knows mark about brain can't
handle is our goal brain too stupid to
handle whatever is going on in this game
go down there go down and hold
yeah get real deep in 800 red good job
murky you so great I'm so proud of you
okay come on come on come on come on I
gotta like mash the spacebar as soon as
I get over there I'm gonna goodness it's
not gonna beat me mm it's not gonna beat
me ah God [ __ ] okay I'm back huh yeah
it's not gonna beat me I know I could
get it the icon changes I see it I gotta
get in that can I run or something well
I just got like this awkward shuffle I
don't even know what this is Susan hurt
Oh
do I even have arms I think I see like
one spindly arm in the back it's like
when we'd walk if he had a cane but he
doesn't have another arm I don't know
what's going on with him but I don't
care I've got to get this I'm gonna get
best I got it is the timing has to be
perfect I gotta get I gotta getta getta
getta getta getta turn is gonna drive me
insane this is gonna drive me insane
this game is designed for oh I got a
good I've got a good it I'm gonna get it
I'm losing my sanity my sanity is oozing
out my headphones Oh deep murky murky
rush murky y'all haven't seen a flashing
images in a long time mostly because
they know that IRAs same and they're
trying to stay away from me good good
for them good for them I think okay yes
yes
okay don't know what's going on but
after 14 minutes of playing
I can finally my progress to the next
level
oh hi well that's not it's not a good
thing
am i here's what the Help section says
it says there I read this before it says
there's a secret run the farther down
the better sometimes you have to do
something crazy illogical but it'll be
wrong game 5 oh I don't know if you know
tell me cuz I don't know
so anyway pile it for yourselves link is
in the description below check it out I
guess oh there's a bigger mystery than
I'm capable of solving it took me five
minutes to get to the frickin portal
thingy whatever the hell that was
farther down the better my anus to
repress gosh darn it no Murphy Mouse and
whole homie Sampson I don't even know
okay anyway I'm all done here so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next